♪ ♪
BERRY: You have, in fact,
after emancipation,
the rise of vigilante groups,
the Ku Klux Klan,
the Knights of
the White Camelias.
They had different
names and different places,
and they saw it as
their job to intimidate and
keep Black people
in their place.
It's much like, today we talk
about the "Karens," you know,
who have felt called upon when
they see some Black person
doing some routine thing that
they think is out of the way,
or they shouldn't be doing it.
That they should take
it upon themselves to
impose a kind of order,
in addition to what ordinary
law enforcement people,
who are official, were doing.
BERRY: And Emmett Till was
the most notorious example.
ALLWOOD: Emmett Till was
a young boy from Chicago.
He was 14 years-old
and as the story goes,
he whistled at a White woman.
And that night,
these White rednecks,
they murdered him.
And his mother decided to have
an open casket so everybody
could view what
happened to her son.
But that's the way
it was in those days.
If you even looked at a
White woman in the South,
you could lose your life.
That was the first time I
had firsthand knowledge and
experience with
the Jim Crow South.
The Ku Klux Klan,
the lynchings.
Just try to imagine
what it was like living
under those conditions.
It just made you angry.
BERRY: This showed you the
force of the vigilante as uh,
a reinforcement of the law.
And with Ahmaud Arbery, the
same kind of thing happened.
WOMAN: I know,
that's fine, that's fine.
BERRY: And this kind of
behavior is no different from
what happened to
Black people earlier in
all kinds of situations.
And so you would think that
the law would be on your side.
And the effort of the
Civil Rights Movement
was to try to get the
law to be on our side,
to fulfill the promises,
as they put it, of the
Declaration of Independence
and of the Constitution.
The language that was there,
but for everybody and
not just for some people.
But of course, in '63,
we had Birmingham.
♪ ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ When the river ♪♪
BERRY: Dogs biting people,
women and children.
Not college students,
but young children,
10 years-old,
9 years-old, 8 years-old,
who were out there protesting.
It was night after night.
Vivid, graphic images
which were undeniable.
There were also, police had
long used a tactic of when
they grabbed somebody that
they wanted to stop or harass,
they would push them down and
then they would put their knee
on the person's neck to
hold them down, you see,
to make them
submit to their power.
And these very brutal images,
which the
President couldn't deny,
because no one
else could deny it,
because you saw it
with your own eyes.
Made it possible for the
movement to go forward.
And so the civil rights
leaders decided that we should
have a march on Washington.
♪ It's knocking at my door ♪♪